[Musica]
come guardate lo spazio intorno a voi lo
osservate con attenzione
io sono un geografo e geografi possono
fare delle sofisticate analisi socio
territoriali
ognuno con il suo approccio
personalmente io osservo con molta
attenzione prima lo spazio fisico dopo
gli esseri umani nella loro fisicità
cercando di capire che cosa possa
corrispondere a loro al loro pensiero
ora immaginate di essere i primi che è
arrivata in una sala di conferenze
sapete quella gradinate 800 posti
tutto è vuoto potete sedervi volete
anche se la scelta del posto non è così
libera come sembra comunque sia vi
sedete dopo un po arriva la seconda
persona uno sconosciuto che arriva e si
siede proprio di fianco a voi tutti noi
penseremo ma proprio qui ma con tutto lo
spazio che c'è
lo spazio era vuoto il sedile era libero
ma noi lo abbiamo considerato come
facente parte della nostra sfera persona
personale adesso immaginato invece che
la seconda persona è un vostro amico una
vostra amica se te li e dopo un po
girate la testa non riconoscete ma vieni
qua si eviti di fianco a me lo spazio le
sedie le luci e le mura sono
assolutamente identiche il fatto è che
la percezione soggettiva dello stesso
spazio fisico cambia in base a che cosa
ho una relazione umana lo spazio fisico
quindi è anche uno spazio mentale e noi
proprio per questo tendiamo a spostarvi
a trasferirvi degli schemi identitari e
questo lo facciamo molto spesso
inconsciamente
lo spazio fisico quindi viene percepito
in modo soggettivo e l'aspetto dello
spazio fisico realtà si relaziona con un
altro spazio che lo spazio profondo del
nostro essere forme viventi e pensanti
e essendo viventi e pensanti e molto
importante la nostra storia vissuta il
nostro passato il nostro presente
le relazioni i ricordi le emozioni
però lo spazio può anche essere uno
spazio rappresentato simbolico se io
dico che qui ora ed ex mestre ha
trasformato questo luogo in un tempio
della cultura
io attribuisco a questo spazio un valore
simbolico però le sedie sono sempre
quelle sono state usate per altro
l'altro giorno ma io gli attribuisco un
valore anche se lo spazio rimane sempre
lo stesso il rapporto con la fisicità
per gli esseri umani è una necessità
così forte così ineludibile che come ho
detto noi trasferiamo nostre idee
bisogni pensieri paure no no no io con
la strada non lo voglio fare lo spazio
fisico diventa quindi un'idea transfer e
vi ricordate nel nostro passato però
qualcuno ancora adesso gli oggetti
transazionali quando eravamo bambini il
peluche momento quel peluche e poi
altre altro altro tipo di cose
naturalmente un capo di vestiario con
cui ci troviamo assolutamente a nostro
agio che l'abbiamo spesso e magari cesti
abbiamo anche più belli esattamente con
quello è un processo così naturale che
non facciamo più caso che in realtà noi
andiamo sempre in quelle di cola e il
cappuccino o lo spritz andiamo a
prenderlo sempre in quel bar quando
andiamo al supermercato
facciamo sostanzialmente sempre sempre
le stesse strade
andiamo da quel tabaccaio anche se più
lontano dell'altro facendo questo noi
inconsciamente mettiamo in atto su di
noi un processo di auto ingabbiamento
che spaziale quello mentale diventa
spaziale un surf che jing perché gli
esseri umani costruiscono confini e
ognuno di noi costruisce ai propri
però va sottolineato che questi confini
sono molti sono flessibili tendono ad
adeguarsi come vi ho detto al tipo di
spazio al tipo di relazioni che noi
instauriamo però con questo noi mettiamo
dei punti fermi nel nostro auto in
cambiamento ma ci sono anche altri punti
fermi provocati dall ingabbiamento il
caching che il gruppo di quelli che noi
consideriamo dei simili mettono nei
nostri confronti il gruppo cui pensiamo
di appartenere come essere umani noi
costruiamo ma vogliamo anche stare
all'interno di isole culturali con
persone che hanno delle affinità vere o
presunte vere o presunte
e tutte queste persone si scambiano i
memi che cos'è un meme meme idea la
definizione data da richard dawkins nel
1976 in un suo libro che si intitolava
il gene egoista è un'unità di
trasmissione culturale unità di
imitazione
in sostanza tutto quello che c entra in
testa i suoni le visioni i segni i
rumori i comportamenti
noi non abbiamo idea di quante robe c
entrano in testa tutti i giorni e
naturalmente tutto questo circo la
nell'isola culturale grazie
all'imitazione certi comportamenti
vengono così ripetuti che diventano
popolari come potete immaginare sui
social con la tecnologia
esplosione dei memi la differenza il
rispetto del rispetto all'invenzione di
dawkins e che adesso i memi siccome
suono e movimento sono quelli che
colpiscono di più le nostre emozioni
adesso si fanno apposta per farli girare
su tik tok o su instagram
alcune di queste che io chiamo
trasposizione ideali
diventano quindi delle iconografie come
le ha definite un geografo francese jean
goldman cioè degli elementi fissi
condivisi e che col passare del tempo
proprio per questo non vengono più
discusse e rappresentano un esempio di
quello di quell ingabbiamento di cui
parlato noi soffriamo l'ingabbiamento
come umano ma questo tipo di
ingabbiamento invece ci dà un senso di
sicurezza i mezzi principali per
sviluppare questo senso questa
percezione di appartenere al gruppo di
far parte della stessa isola culturale
sono sostanzialmente due sono la
condivisione della lingua e la
manifestazione visibile
della presunta comune appartenenza i
vestiti le abitudini gli stessi
comportamenti e naturali e naturalmente
anche certi caratteri somatici
nessuno si mette davanti ai bambini a
dire venite qui che vi faccio una
lezione teorica sulle regole del
contratto sociale
anche perché le imparano per imitazione
autonomamente ben prima di andare a
scuola ben prima di avere una capacità
di ragionamento articolato e razionale
lo imparano dal tipo di relazione che le
regole diventano i sì e il no dei
genitori oi comportamenti delle persone
che frequentano più abitualmente perché
noi esseri umani siamo delle poderose
macchine di apprendimento e la prendiamo
soprattutto la gran parte della nostra
vita di relazione fate di me mi e di
queste iconografie che progressivamente
diventano quelle che si chiamano i
valori comuni
le tradizioni quello che è giusto quello
che è sbagliato è una trasmissione
quotidiana di comportamenti e
atteggiamenti molto sofisticata
articolata potente però siamo esseri
umani
individualisti ognuno ci mette del suo
per cui me mi che ci scambiamo non
restano mai quasi mai uguali per cui
nella gran parte ci sono sempre si
innescano delle piccole mutazioni
il riconoscimento consapevole
dell'identità personale e di gruppo e
molto molto soggettivo e in parte solo
in parte volontario non conflittuale ma
può diventare conflittuale non dipende
dallo spazio fisico da come fatto ma
dipende ancora una volta nostro tipo di
relazioni e anche dalla struttura
l'assetto di potere dell'isola culturale
in cui noi viviamo dal tipo di piramide
del socio economica in cui noi siamo
immersi e quindi quello che conta non è
solo chi comanda in uno specifico
territorio ma come comanda in quel
territorio
quando non ci sono confini per
proteggere o perché cercare di
proteggere quello che noi immaginiamo
sia la nostra visione identitaria li
creiamo quindi muri barriere separazioni
o anche
separazione allontanamento
perché mettere i confini è un'operazione
profondamente umana spero di avervi in
qualche modo convinto non
necessariamente conflittuale ma la
costruzione dell'altro nel nostro spazio
mentale dello straniero del diverso è di
per se stesso un meccanismo di
separazione e quindi tendenzialmente
ostile più o meno consapevole anche
questo dipende dall'ambiente in cui
abbiamo vissuto in cui viviamo e dalla
nostra storia personale e così essendo
un geografo politico anche nella realtà
geopolitica noi troviamo un sacco di
confini e purtroppo molti di questi sono
stati utilizzati spesso per fare la
guerra però si può fare diversamente
perché quello che succede in pratica
ovunque nel mondo e molto molto vario
il sudtirolo è stato considerato ed è
considerato internazionalmente come un
modo molto pratico ed efficace di
risolvere un problema tra due gruppi
linguistici diversi e per cercare di
superare conflitti del passato perché il
tedesco prima e l'italiano dopo sono
diventati lingua dominante
si è pensato di separare con dei confini
linguistici maggioritarie seguendo i
crinali alpini quindi un confine
cosiddetto naturale che tradizionalmente
aveva tenuto separate le due comunità ma
in piccole aree questi confini naturali
alta cedono il passo all appartenenza
linguistica per cui i ladini sono dalla
parte del veneto dalla parte della
provincia di bolzano e in altre parti
invece si sono fatte delle redazioni
derivazioni che superano il crinale per
andare a inglobare linguisticamente una
piccola una piccola area
un altro esempio è quello dell'irlanda
del nord più quasi trent'anni di
troubles di problemi di scontri che ha
voluto dire attentati omicidi mirati
repressione fortissima all'esercito
inglese che spara contro le
manifestazioni hanno costruito muri
barriere soprattutto a belfast sono più
di ottanta e che ci sono ancora e ci
viene presentata questa cosa come un
conflitto religioso per protestanti e
cattolici ma in realtà la protesta era
contro l'inferiorità politico sociale
dei cattolici si arriva una pace nel
1998 e questo ha fatto diminuire
moltissimo le tensioni non le ha fatte
scomparire perché noi esseri umani ci
mettiamo tempo a cambiare le iconografie
però adesso la gran parte dei cittadini
della repubblica d'irlanda e
dell'irlanda del nord non vuole più
ritornare un confine rigido tra le due
tra le due zone ma poi interviene un
cambiamento politico che è quello della
break sit che quindi rivendica la
sovranità e quindi si ritorna nel quadro
spaziale dello stato territoriale
unitario e omogeneo e questi stati i
confini da qualche parte li devono
mettere
nel mondo ci sono molte anche lavoro
exclave cioè piccoli territori che sono
staccati dal dal grande stato a cui
fanno riferimento che vivono
pacificamente
quando succede quando con poche regole
burocratiche con molte limitazioni si
consentono i collegamenti delle persone
e il movimento delle cose
perché i confini umani sia singoli che
di gruppo vi ho detto che sono
flessibili
però anche contraddittori nel senso che
riferito ai confini fisici in certi casi
il fiume il crinale della montagna del
babbo anche gli edifici
rivendicati come una prova certa fisica
che quel gruppo deve stare insieme
in altri casi gli stessi elementi un
fiume un edificio un crinale sono una
prova che quel gruppo invece
assolutamente non può non può stare
insieme e la lingua la carezza della
lingua che comprendiamo diceva il
geografo francese lizeroux e clou è il
collante sociale principale dell'isola
culturale perché serve alla trasmissione
di quelli che vi ho detto che sono i
memi idea però sostanzialmente quello
che ho visto da geo politico e che tutti
i gruppi umani sono capaci di auto
organizzarsi con riferimenti fisici e
iconografici che vanno ben oltre al di
là dello stato o dei confini naturali da
questo punto di vista siamo molto molto
flessibili e quindi è la pretesa della
fissità dei confini che può innescare
meccanismi di conflittualità per che
cozza con meccanismi umani profondi e
per andare oltre a questa cosa ci vuole
consapevolezza ma soprattutto la volontà
e non è facile perché bisogna pensarlo
in un modo diverso più funzionale più
flessibile per facilitare le relazioni
non per difendere degli assetti di
potere
proprio per questo l'unione europea dopo
secoli e secoli di guerre per i confini
ha deciso di finanziare lungo tutti i
confini interni degli stati membri e
anche degli stati non membri dei
progetti di cooperazione politica ed
economica a cavallo dei confini
però nella narrazione mediatica faccetti
fateci caso questa informazione molto
marginale oppure non c'è proprio per
niente lo fa da moltissimo tempo
eppure è un modo molto pratico che ha
mostrato la sua efficacia di cambiare il
senso dei confini di trasformarli da
posto di separazione al luogo di
incontro e di collaborazione
il fatto è che negli ultimi 20 anni
il crescente arrivo di essere umani
altri
soprattutto dopo la crisi siriana del
2015 2016 ha irrigidito tutti i confini
esterni dell'unione per cui sono stati
messi in piedi fisicamente muri e
barriere filo spinato e questo per
arrivare alla conclusione direi che di
nuovo dimostra quanto sia mentale ma
anche fisico lo spazio che noi
immaginiamo per chi sconosciuto vuole
sedere di fianco a noi e allora forse
bisogna moltiplicare i confini può
sembrare un paradosso ma non ricordare
che sono tanti che li facciamo noi
e come diceva di nuovo e le serie clou
però si possono cambiare perché
dall'essere umano che nasce la volontà
creatrice di costruire e ricostruire il
mondo
e così i confini come si costruiscono si
possono
beh non cancellarli però gestirli
renderli funzionali utili ma certo
niente per cui combattere e morire come
diceva john lennon nella sua canzone
imagine
[Applauso]
[Musica]